[Music]
welcome to getting started with artifact
registry
today i'll show you how to deploy a
container stored in an
artifact registry repository to google
kubernetes engine
if you're new to artifact registry i
recommend you check out the last episode
of getting started
or the documentation before proceeding
with that in mind
let's walk through deploying to gke now
there's a good chance that if you're
watching this video
you already know about google kubernetes
engine but to get everyone up to speed
let's have a quick overview
gke is an enterprise grade platform for
containerized applications
including state full and state lists ai
and ml
linux and windows complex and simple web
apps
api and backend services you can use gka
to leverage
industry-first features like 4-way
auto-scaling and no stress management
you can also optimize gpu and tpu
provisioning
use integrated developer tools and get
multi-cluster support from sres
so why use artifact registry then with
gke
using artifact registry with gka gives
you the ability to manage
all of your artifacts in one place so
for example
you can build maven packages push them
to artifact registry
containerize them with cloud build and
jib and then deploy them
to gke all while using consistent im
across the build
process artifact management and gke
artifact registry also enables you to
run in fully regionalized stacks
so with artifact registry an australian
or south american customer can run gk
clusters
and manage container images in the same
region and pay
no egress costs while they pull images
pretty sweet huh so without further ado
let's deploy to gke first start with new
or existing code
here's a simple go hello world app that
i'm going to use in my container
you can also take a look at my docker
file here for kicks
so it's pretty much boilerplate see
below for a link to the documentation
where you can see
this file in detail i'm using cloud
build to build this project
but keep in mind that you don't have to
using cloud build allows you to
automatically push the image to artifact
registry
which i like because it streamlines the
deploy process
these next couple steps are for building
with cloud build
if you don't already know your cloud
project id you can get it
by running this command now create a
file called
cloudbuild.yaml here's the contents of
that file
but don't worry about rushing to pause
the video so you can copy this down
you can find this code in the
documentation which of course is linked
below
these variables repository and image are
used for the repository name
and the name of the image in the
repository so that they can be replaced
at build time
using custom cloud-build substitutions
this is very useful if you want to use
the same build config file to push
images to repositories
for different environments such as
testing staging and or production
for example this command would
substitute drain pipe for the repository
name
and my image for the image name
i run this command to submit my
container to build using cloud build
it is then stored using artifact
registry in the drainpipe repository
now that you have a project built and
ready to go you may need to configure
access to your container
check the docs to see the minimum
required gke versions to create clusters
that have default permissions to pull
containers from docker repositories in
the same project
if you are not using one of these gk
versions you will need to configure
access to pull containers using
kubernetes image full secrets
if you need to access containers from
repositories in another project then you
need to grant
read permission on that repository to
the identity being used to pull the
image
once that access is configured you can
run an artifact registry image on a gk
cluster
using this command where name is the
name you've given the object
location is the regional or
multi-regional location of your
repository
project id is of course your google
cloud project
id repository is the name of the
repository where the image is stored
image is the name of the image in the
repository and tag is the tag for the
image version that you want to pull
so for my drain pipe project i'd use
this command and now my image that's
stored in an artifact registry
repository
is deployed to gke want to see more on
deploying to google kubernetes engine
with artifact registry
check out the artifact registry quick
start for docker and the artifact
registry guide on integrating with
google kubernetes engine
do you have any questions about artifact
registry feel free to comment below
or tweet at me thanks for watching and
i'll see you
on the next getting started with
artifact registry